this is my driver's license right here
it's blurred right now but in a moment
i'm going to show you the real thing
to demonstrate how serious identity
theft is guys
i'm going to show it to you but you got
to swear you're not going to use this
information against me
swear it three two
one joke's on you
i would never show you my driver's
license why because of a little rule
that i learned from the office
identity theft is not a joke jim
identity theft is not a joke
okay guys we're not gonna joke around
about it here
or anywhere else because it's not funny
you know who knows that
mr beast mr beast recently had
his identity stolen by hackers
who advertised mr beast cards
playstation cards and
all this stuff on youtube i mean how
insulting at least do it on instagram
that's not his own platform on youtube
it's like
kicking the guy on his own turf you know
what i mean and mr b says he's going to
get lawyers involved and all this stuff
but i think it brings up an interesting
discussion
of just like ads in general why was this
allowed in the first place
and also this isn't the only time it's
happened so let's let's talk about it a
little bit
right so i think mr beast is probably
the biggest person this has happened to
but this has been happening consistently
to bigger and bigger creators
we had it happen to ksi right huge
creator
he also said basically same exact scam
mkbhd recently pointed out that
he had been photoshopped into a gaming
chair that he had
no affiliation with at all and like this
gaming chair company just photoshopped
his body into their chair
and basically we're running ads on it
for years i mean
literally for years and i know some of
you might be saying
that's not identity theft they didn't
get his social security number whatever
it is identity theft when somebody's
taking your likeness and then pretending
making it seem like you're affiliated
with a product and the question is like
what can you do i mean a lot of these
people talk about you know
they report the ads but it doesn't do
any good because just another account is
set up even in the mr beast case
it wasn't just one account that was
running these ads it was like
three accounts that were running the ads
already and i'm sure once those are shut
down
three more will just pop up so the
question is what do you really do well i
think
a really good response was actually done
by shelby church if you guys
don't already know who she is great
quality youtube channel has questionable
taste in
amazon sellers not gonna lie but overall
a really good channel and her face has
been used
many times by scammers i've seen this ad
probably a million times myself
and she finally got fed up with
reporting these ads and seeing them come
right back up i reported it
it got taken down and i thought all was
well a couple days later though another
ad popped up this time from a different
person so she decided to follow one down
the rabbit hole and she found out that
they're basically some survey apps and
like some like uh
you know apps where you make money by
selling personal information about
yourself
and her conclusion is pretty pretty on
the money
you'll probably just end up getting a
bunch of spam calls and emails
but even that to me is not worth five
dollars like i will pay a hundred
dollars
to not get any more spam calls and
emails exactly especially when you
consider that these companies will steal
your information
without your consent imagine what
they'll do with your information that
you give them
with your consent they're using famous
youtubers
identities to get people to click on
them but the question is
what is to be done about it i mean i
mean honestly i don't think getting
lawyers involved will do much good
first of all who knows if the people are
even located in the united states
uh who knows if this is one company or
several companies i mean i think it
would just be
a logistical nightmare the bigger
question is why isn't youtube doing
anything more
and people have repeatedly asked them to
do something more
because i don't know if you guys know
this but this this is very similar to
the bitcoin scam i mean that's
another example of identity theft
they'll have some video of like
steve jobs or you know bill gates up
there and they'll say
give me one get bitcoin i'll give you
two bitcoin and they're relying on the
reputation of the person
in the video now people have been
begging youtube to get this under
control for
months now and they just seem to not be
able to do it even on my channel it was
recently advertised
which you know i'm used to scams getting
run on my channel but
come on youtube i mean a bitcoin scam
really
i thought we were above that i thought
we were passed out so they can't even
get that under control and i think it's
just because they've refused to hire
enough human
reviewers youtube tends to have an
algorithm first approach to everything
they want to solve
everything with computer algorithms and
i get it
but at the same time it's never quite
there
and i think you need that human
moderation to kind of tweak it
when it when it's not there right i
think youtube is sometimes overly
optimistic on what their algorithms can
do and can't do and
i get it they have a massive catalog of
videos that
can't possibly be checked by an
individual every time
but when you're running ads these ads
should be
checked i mean when you have a youtuber
reporting multiple ads stealing their
identity
that shouldn't be happening right one
time should be enough like one time
you know shame on me or what whatever
this thing is
two times shame on you i don't know
shame on you shame on me
i don't that saying probably doesn't
even apply here i apologize for even
bringing that into this conversation
but the point is youtube has to do
something and thankfully someone is
actually pushing for that so this is a
cool part of the conversation
which is that steve wozniak you know
like the co-founder of apple
is actually really putting some pressure
on youtube with the new
lawsuit that came out like last month we
covered it a little bit
but basically the details are that he's
fed up with his identity being stolen by
these bitcoin scams he's trying to get
youtube to basically be held accountable
for it
now one of the things i really love
about how he's handling the cases
he was asked you know why didn't you
just use your connections as steve
wozniak you know you can get in touch
with the guys at youtube
come on and his answer here really like
blew me away did you ever reach out to
the ceo of youtube
uh susan wojcicki i don't i don't go
around and use my privilege because on
my name
we did it as a normal person online
there are ways to fill out forms and
data
and i don't like to try to pull strings
and go around things the way
normal average people can't this is a
guy who wants to be treated as a member
of the masses
and he wants to see what it's like what
the rest of us are experiencing on
youtube day to day
you know i don't have a youtube rep
steve wozniak doesn't want a youtube rep
and i love that he's fighting for the
little guy here and honestly that's what
you need
you need a big guy with capital to bring
a lawsuit against
a big company and he's actually doing it
so
this might be the one thing that forces
youtube's hand on this to actually
proactively intervene on these identity
theft cases
but apart from that apart from wozniak
saving the day i really can't see it
getting much better
and i think people like mr b should just
save their money and tell their fans not
to click on these ads because
i don't think there's anything you can
do what are you going to do sue them
like 10 more just going to pop up
ultimately they're just arbitraging on
google's ad prices combined with how
many people click on it
and how much ad revenue they get from
those actual downloads so unless you can
interfere with that
actually making sense uh you're not
going to shut it down
unless youtube does something which in
the past
given their path performance doesn't
seem likely so anyway let me know what
you guys think of this situation do you
think youtube should be held accountable
for this do you think it's not their
responsibility on
creators should just suck it up i don't
know it's interesting situation
let me know what you think anyway that's
it see
[Music]
[Music]
the coffin comes along